The deaths of beloved TV characters
can shock viewers like nothing else.
They might feel sudden, but they've
often been planned years in advance.
So we're here to examine those characters
who were doomed from episode one.
Premiering on Starz in 2014, the
crime drama Power follows nightclub
owner and drug kingpin James "Ghost" St.
Patrick. He's a family man and entrepreneur
who poses as a pillar of the community on
the strength of his rags-to-riches façade.
Secretly, his best friend is his partner in
literal crime, and the first season sees him
embark upon an extramarital affair
with his middle school sweetheart.
Ghost is brought to life by actor Omari Hardwick,
who entices viewers with his sharp suits,
menacing focus, and chiseled good looks. Ghost's
secret life of crime is destined to catch up to
him in the end, though. In the final season, he's
shot dead by his son Tariq. As it turns out, Power
creator Courtney A. Kemp always planned to have
Ghost die. As she wrote in the Los Angeles Times,
"The series is about consequences for
their actions. The characters always
cause their own deaths, one way or another."
Sons of Anarchy premiered on FX in 2008,
hooking fans with its killer characters
and gruesome scenes of gun violence and gang
battles, and lead character Jax Teller quickly
became beloved by fans. As the prodigal son who's
set to take charge of the California motorcycle
crew his father once led, he must manage his
overbearing mother, life as a new father,
and his own torn emotions over the one who
got away. Over the course of seven seasons,
he works to transform the trajectory of his
crew so that violence and criminal activity
are no longer at the forefront of their lives.
During this time, he and his loved ones endure
plenty of terrifying struggles. In the end, he
sacrifices himself for the well-being of the crew.
This sounds like a lot for writers to put a
character through, but in a 2014 interview
with E!, executive producer Paris Barclay made
it clear that this was always the plan for Jax.
As he put it,
"I knew that he wasn't going to end up at
a carnival buying snow cones for his sons
and that was the last shot. I always
knew this was going to end badly."
"What happens at the end of the day?"
"The bad guys lose."
In 2018, the Sons of Anarchy legacy continued
with the premiere of the spinoff Mayans M.C.,
which centers on a tight-knit
motorcycle crew in Mexico.
It remains to be seen if the lead actor on that
show will also experience a shocking demise.
Michael K. Williams is a phenomenal actor
who often portrays conflicted individuals
who tend to overshadow the protagonists.
From Chalky White on Boardwalk Empire
to Montrose Freeman on Lovecraft Country, he
seamlessly transforms into dark and enigmatic
characters that audiences grow to love. On the
HBO series The Wire, he played Omar Little, a
stick-up guy who robs drug dealers and keeps them
on their toes. The Baltimore-set crime drama has
been hailed as a classic and frequently cited as
one of the greatest shows in television history.
Omar stands out as an especially great part of
the series, thanks to the strategic way he runs
the streets, his well-rounded moral compass,
and his unique status as a gay man. TV viewers
in the early 2000s had truly never before seen a
queer character like Omar on a gritty crime show.
In the final season, Omar is killed in a
convenience store by a young drug dealer.
In 2008, Williams shared his feelings
about his character's death with MTV News,
as he revealed that he'd always known
it was going to happen. As he put it,
"It took me for a loop. I was also saddened. Not
that he was dying, 'cause when I got the job,
they told me season one Omar was only going
to be around for seven episodes. 'After that,
expect a bullet.' It still hurt. Five years, you
lock with this dude, you know the dude real well."
He added,
"The people of Baltimore, I got to know
the streets, how they walk, how they eat,
how they dress. I soaked all of that up. I
feel like I lost one of my best friends."
"A man got to have a code."
In House of Cards' first season, newspaper
journalist Zoe Barnes is the key to Frank
Underwood's demise. Underwood holds many secrets.
Some have the power to destroy his growing
political career, while others could destroy
his calculated marriage. Zoe is also seduced
by the criminal congressman. As she learns more
about him, she shares her intel with her boss,
but she also grows fearful as Frank begins to
stalk and antagonize her. He ultimately follows
her into a subway station and pushes her onto the
tracks. Her death is swift, cold, and shocking.
House of Cards executive producer David Fincher
usually employs a dark visual style to his films,
so perhaps it's no surprise that his foray into
TV followed suit. Nevertheless, fans were blown
away by the sinister scene. When series creator
Beau Willimon spoke with The Hollywood Reporter
in 2014, he revealed that Zoe's death had been
planned from the beginning. As he explained,
"We told Kate Mara from the get-go.
I always knew that Zoe was going to meet her
maker in the first episode of season two."
He later added,
"She is so wonderful that as
we got closer to doing it,
we reconsidered for a second,
then we stuck to our guts."
Amazon's The Boys explores an alternate universe
in which people with extraordinary gifts are
labeled "Supes," and attract the attention of
conglomerates. The powerful corporation Vought
International has created a team of celebrity
Supes called the Seven, who fight crime and
work to save humanity. But this work is actually
a façade. When the cameras and capes are off,
many members of the Seven lead challenging
lives, and are even dangers to humanity.
Take for example, Lamplighter, a former member
of the Seven played by Shawn Ashmore who has the
ability to set things ablaze. He's mentioned
quite a bit in season one, though he doesn't
actually appear until season two. The truth about
his complex allegiances is eventually revealed,
and then he sets himself on fire. After
the episode aired, Ashmore told TV Line,
"It was such a bold choice. The way that I
look at death scenes is if you’re gonna go
out on a show or on a film, it better
be good, and it better be impactful."
When Lost premiered on ABC in 2004, it seemed
fairly straightforward, as a group of plane
crash survivors came together to figure out life
on a deserted island. But over the course of
its six-season run, it became clear over and
over again that it was anything but simple.
There are supernatural elements to the island,
and every survivor has a complicated past that
led them there. Ana Lucia Cortez, for
one, was on the plane's tail section
and emerged as a leader in season two. She puts
her LAPD skills to use on the island, but she
also gains a lot of enemies in doing so. She's
eventually killed by fellow survivor Michael.
In a 2006 interview with TV Guide,
Lost showrunners Damon Lindelof
and Carlton Cuse discussed details about Ana
Lucia's arc. As they developed the character
and put the casting word out, they heard
from Michelle Rodriguez's agent that she
was interested in the role, but only
for one season. As Lindelof recalled,
"She wanted to do one kick-ass
arc, as she described it,
and we basically started to wrap our
brains around her energy and say,
'Yeah, we'll bring you on the show and then
we'll kill you off at the end of the year.'"
"I can't do this anymore."
When Tara Knowles pops up on Sons of Anarchy in
Charming, California, Jax Teller is stunned. They
loved each other in high school, but Tara left to
focus on her studies. She comes back as a doctor,
finding Jax in pretty bad shape, with
a drug-addicted girlfriend and a new
baby. Despite their hiccups and hurdles, the
sweethearts manage to stick it out, as they
get married and have a son of their own. But Tara
is always at odds with Jax's overbearing mother,
Gemma. For her part, Gemma is wary of Tara's
true intentions, while also desiring to
maintain her position as the most important
woman in her son's life. She ends up killing
Tara while acting on false information. Jax is
devastated and never recovers from the pain.
Katey Sagal, who played Gemma and is married
to show creator Kurt Sutter, had hoped that
he would change his mind about Tara's death.
But Sutter stood firm, having decided that
Jax needed the major emotional shift that this
provided as the series approached its ending.
Over the course of Lost's six seasons, viewers
discover that Jack Shephard is more than the
self-appointed leader of the survivors. He's
also been connected to them for years. Through
flashbacks, these links are revealed, as are
the shameful mistakes of his past that led
him to Oceanic Flight 815. He grapples with
his estranged relationship with his father,
his love for Kate, and his animosity for
Sawyer, who challenges Jack's leadership.
Early versions of Lost actually killed Jack in
the pilot and made Kate the group's leader. As
critic Alan Sepinwall wrote in his
book The Revolution Was Televised,
"In the vein of Alfred Hitchcock's Psycho [...]
they planned to pull the rug out from under the
audience by killing Jack midway through the
first episode, forcing Kate to take charge."
Of course, Jack instead lives and gets off the
island, only to return with other survivors
who made it home. The big mystery of the show
ends up being whether the survivors are dead,
existing in an alternate universe, or
experiencing some kind of strange shared dream.
And ultimately, Jack does end up biting the
bullet, just much later than originally planned.
The FX drama Pose is loud, proud, and
unapologetic. Set in New York beginning
in the late 80s, it follows the lives of gay and
transgender people who participate in the city's
underground ballroom scene, brought to life by
a cast that consists of multiple trans actors.
In 2019, co-creator Ryan Murphy and producer
Janet Mock talked with Deadline about the
decision to have fan favorite Candy
Ferocity killed in the second season.
Played by Angelica Ross, Candy is a member
of the House of Ferocity who's often mocked
by ballroom announcer Pray Tell. But she's true to
her name as a ferocious force to be reckoned with,
and her death is deeply felt in
the community. Mock told Deadline,
"Our hardest thing was which character
[to kill]. So once we figured out which
character [...] we kind of plotted the whole
first half of the season around losing Candy
and really showing what that would look like."
The decision was necessary to the story as they
had built it, but Mock and Murphy also felt it
was important to shed light on the violence that
trans women were facing then and still face today.
"We will never again get the opportunity to
tell her what she meant to us, to
thank her for what she gave us."
On the British period drama Downton Abbey, Lady
Sybil Crawley, as played by Jessica Brown-Findlay,
is the youngest daughter of Robert and Cora
Crawley, the Earl and Countess of Grantham.
Along with her very different sisters, she
maneuvers through high society and the complicated
social pressures that come with her position.
She makes great efforts to set herself apart,
intermingling with classes deemed lesser than
her own. She even falls in love with an Irish
driver named Tom, spurning the turned-up
noses of her aristocratic family. The
couple are able to welcome a daughter, but Sybil
tragically dies from childbirth complications.
Worried about being stuck on a never-ending
series, Brown-Findlay set her terms well before
the show began. As Downton Abbey creator
Julian Fellowes told Vanity Fair in 2015,
"Jessica had said she was going
to leave right from the beginning.
She said, 'I'm doing three years, then
I'm leaving.' So that was all worked out."
"Is there anything we should do, Mr. Carson?"
"Carry on, Daisy, as we all must."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about
your favorite TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.